[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Christian sieers ihn allen
einen guten Freitagabend es gibt Gäste
die sind unkompliziert und locker da ist
ein entspannter Plausch kein Problem es
gibt schwierige Gäste mit denen einiges
verbindet und vieles trennt das wird
dann eher heikel so ist es privat so ist
es in der großen Politik der
Bundeskanzler hat heute einen Gast beim
Abendessen mit dem es in der
Vergangenheit häufig Krach gab und
gerade in der Bewertung der Lage in
Nahost jetzt noch viel mehr der aber zu
wichtig ist als dass er einfach
ausgeladen werden könnte man braucht
einander und deshalb ist heute ein
diplomatisches Kunststück gefragt kte
reden mit dem Staatspräsidenten der
Türkei ohne dass es zum eklar kommt
Klaus brotbeck
berichtet einer freut sich dann doch
über diesen Gast die Kolonne von Reb TB
Erdogan kurz vor 4:30 es geht quer durch
Berlin schön für
ihn später gut 300 m weiter
atmosphärisch etliche gerade Kühler
Schloss belvü Amtssitz des
Bundespräsidenten die nächste
Begrüßung über Inhalte des
anschließenden Gesprächs von Präsident
zu Präsident wird nichts
mitgeteilt das Klima des Gesprächs aber
lässt sich hier noch vorab leicht
ablesen Eintrag ins Goldene Buch ein
großwort wäre diplomatisch üblich
Erdogan schreibt sein
Namen das
war's politisch kühl auch der Auftakt
vor dem Kanzleramt immerhin ein Lächeln
fast sogar zwei sehr schnell aber kommen
beide danach auf Betriebstemperatur
befeuert von zahlreichen
Meinungsunterschieden hier nur die zum
Krieg in
Israel des kennt der weiß unsere
Solidarität mit Israel steht außer Frage
israel hat das völkerrechtlich
verbriefte Recht sich zu
verteidigen psychologisch wenn man sich
in der Position eines Schuldigen sieht
kann man die Situation derzeit in Israel
und Palästina nicht bewiten deswegen
kann ich aus einer komfortablen
Situation sprechen denn wir fühlen uns
gegenüber Israel nicht schuldig sonst
könnten wir nicht so frei reden wir
haben nicht die Bürde des
Holocaust Erdogan fordert humanitäre
Feuerpausen das zu unterstützen habe er
auch Steinmeer gebeten zur Lage der
Geiseln in Hand der Hamas sagt
er wenn wir über Geiseln reden dann
müssen wir doch auch in Betracht Zehen
dass neben den Geiseln die die Hamas hat
auch in Israel palästinens als Geiseln
in Haft sind das sind um einiges
mehr GA ist ja auch Geisel der Hamas die
für ihre eigenen machtpläne
gewissermaßen die Bevölkerung dort als
Schutzschild benutzt es ging natürlich
um mehr um Migration den Beitritt der
Türkei in die EU um die Lieferung von
eurofighern an Ankara ohne Presse ab
morgen dann werden beide dazu wohl
berichten was sie selbst am liebsten
hören Erdogan dann wieder zu
Hause 3 Millionen aus der Türkei
stammende Menschen leben hier in
Deutschland manche von ihnen sagen das
sollte ein politbesuch wie jeder andere
sein andere begrüßen Erdogan als ihren
Präsidenten von den abgegebenen Stimmen
aus Deutschland hat Erdogan bei der
letzten Wahl in der Türkei 67% bekommen
aber was heißt das jetzt konkret Ina
Baltes für Turan de meni ist Erdogan ein
großer Präsident mit Weitblick so sagt
er und Durchsetzungskraft rund 55 000
Follower hat der influencer aus
Darmstadt in seinen Post spricht er
offensichtlich vielen Deutschtürken aus
der Seele wir hatten Präsidenten vor
seiner Amtszeit die sich wirklich gar
nicht um uns gekümmert haben die
auslandlebenden und wir haben jetzt
einen Präsidenten zum Glück seit
mehreren Jahren seit fast inzwischen 10
15 Jahren der sich wirklich aktiv für
uns einsetzt doch folgt seinem Idol
nicht in allem er nennt die Hamas
explizit eine
Terrororganisation gleichzeitig völliges
Unverständnis gegenüber der deutschen
Politik ich habe das Gefühl dass
Deutschland sich immer noch so schuldig
fühlt dass sie koste ist was es wolle
hinter der Seite von Israel sch und das
ist falsch Deutschland muss lernen dass
ehemalige Opfer auch zu Täter werden
können politische Aktivisten wie de meni
haben wohl großen Einfluss auf die
Deutschtürken Turul selmanolu mit über
follow auf X schreibt an die deutschen
Medien seid ihr komplett verblödet wie
kann man Antisemitismus und Israelkritik
nicht auseinanderhten 13000 Follower hat
junus celeb auf tiktok der fassungslos
ist über die Blockade des Gazastreifens
wegen ihrer Blockade kommen unschuldige
Menschen ums Leben schämen sollten sich
dafür die Medien und die deutschen
Politiker und jeder der bei diesem
Verbrechen am Schweigen ist extrem
emotional wird die Debatte geführt viele
Deutschtürken fühlen sich dabei den
Palästinensern eng verbunden sie stehen
mehrheitlich auf der Seite der
Palästinenser weil es eine
leidgeschichte gibt aus der muslimischen
Perspektive die die Palästinenser
betrifft und sie haben natürlich
aufgrund der gemeinsamen Religion eine
ganz andere Affinität zum Leid der
Palästinenser
als zu den Angriffen und Terrorakten
gegenüber Israel und sochst das
Verständnis für die deutsche Sicht und
die deutschen Medien wir spüren das bei
unseren Dreharbeiten im türkischen
Viertel von
Köln lasst es ich habe keine Lust auf
Probleme sagt diese
Frau meine Meinung ist wenn unser
Präsident Erdogan etwas entscheidet und
kritisiert dann ist das
berechtigt sie möchten nicht als Feinde
Israels abgestempelt werden auch deshalb
redet kaum jemand mit
uns ich wurde auch schon als Terroristen
abgestempmpelt nur weil ich halt pro
palästinensische Post auf Instagram
geäußert und gepostet habe und dabei bin
ich halt keine Terroristen ich bin halt
für den Frieden wir müssen sehr viel
Arbeit leisten und in Ruhe miteinander
kommunizieren miteinander kommunizieren
das gilt für den Krieg im Nahen Osten
aber wohl auch für das Verhältnis
zwischen den Deutschtürken und der
Mehrheitsgesellschaft der Graben ist
tiefer
geworden zu Erdogans Besuch und seiner
Rolle im narostkonflikt später im heute
journal Update ein Interview mit der CDU
Abgeordneten serab Güller Israel gegen
die Hamas die reguläre Armee eines
demokratischen Staates gegen eine
Terrororganisation mit gerill Methoden
das heißt für Israel es muss auch
kämpfen um die öffentliche Meinung zumal
jedes Bild eines durch israelische
Angriffe getöteten Kindes den
Terroristen von Hamas in die Hände
spielt für diesen Krieg um die
internationale Wahrnehmung unterhält
Israels Armee eine ganze Teilung ich
rede gleich mit dem Armeesprecher erst
die Situation im tatsächlichen Krieg dem
der Tote fordert auch heute wieder
Dominik
lesmeister es sind Bilder der Verwüstung
Luftangriff heute morgen in hananjunis
im Süden des Gazastreifens etwa eine
Million Palästinenser waren der
Aufforderung Israels gefolgt sind in den
Süden geflüchtet doch sicher sei man
hier keineswegs sagen die
Menschen sie sagen der Süden sei sicher
welche Sicherheit diese Bilder zeigen
der Welt wie sicher der Süden
ist sie bringen die Verletzten ins
Krankenhaus von
janunis es sind viele Kinder darunter
chaotische Szenen spielen sich ab
al war mit ihrer Familie aus dem Norden
geflüchtet suchte Zuflucht
hier alle meine Brüder sind gestorben
und meine Mutter nur meine Tochter hat
überlebt die israelische Armee erklärt
die Luftangriffe richteten sich gegen
Extremisten und Einrichtungen der
Hammers doch israels Ministerpräsident
Netanyahu gesteht zivile Opfer ein im
Interview mit dem uscenter
CBS jeder Tod eines Zivilisten ist eine
Tragödie wir versuchen alles in unserer
Macht stehende zu tun um Zivilisten aus
der Gefahrenzone zu bringen während die
Hamas alles tut um sie dort festzuhalten
wir versuchen den Job so zu erledigen
dass es möglichst wenige zivile Opfer
gibt aber wir sind aber leider nicht
erfolgreich das Leid der zivilen Opfer
auch auf der israelischen Seite und 240
Geiseln darunter Kinder befinden sich
noch immer in der Gewalt der Hamas
bringt sie nach Hause fordern sie auf
ihrem Marsch von telaviv nach Jerusalem
morgen wollen sie ankommen und auf das
Schicksal der Familien aufmerksam
machen
human als Mensch als Großmutter und als
stolzer Bürger
Israels ich möchte dass die Regierung
alles tut um sie nach Hause zu
bringen alles hilft alles was weltweit
getan wird auch von Regierungen ich
glaube daran dass es am Ende Hamas
erhören wird und dass ich sie
freilassen nach den Geiseln suchte das
israelische Militär auch bei ihrem
Einsatz im alschifer Krankenhaus heute
nun veröffentlicht dieee ein Video das
einen Tunneleingang der ham auf ände der
Klinik zeigen soll auch ein Fahrzeug mit
Waffen sei sichergestellt worden von
einer großen Kommandozentrale gibt es
bisher aber keine
Bilder Israels Generalstabschef hat eine
Ausweitung der Einsätze in Gaza
angekündigt wir sind kurz davor das
militärische System im nördlichen
Gazastreifen zu zerschlagen wir werden
in anderen Gebieten weitermachen sagt er
Arie schalika ist Sprecher der
israelischen Armee er ist in Deutschland
geboren und jetzt live bei uns aus einem
Vorort von Tel Aviv guten Abend Herr
Major Shalom lieber Christian was hat
man sich denn wie hat man sich denn
diese Ausweitung der botenoffensive auf
den Süden von Gaza jetzt ganz konkret
vorzustellen na ja also zum ersten sind
wir nach wie vor im nördlichen Teil des
Gazastreifens unterwegs und das
insbesondere in der Stadt Gaza City wo
die Hochburg der Terrororganisation
hamass sich befindet das insbesondere
natürlich auch in einer Anzahl von
Krankenhäusern jedoch gibt es im
gazaastreifen noch zwei weitere Teile
und zwar den mittleren und den südlichen
Teil insbesondere die Großstädte
chanunes und rafir von wo nach wie vor
auf Israel mit Raketen geschossen wird
erst heute sind dutzende Raketen aus
diesen Teilen des gasastreifens auf Tel
Aviv abgefeuert worden jetzt sagt
die Armee auch vier Städte im Süden
sollten verlassen werden von den
Menschen Israel warnt sie dass sie sonst
wenn sie zu Hause bleiben dort
bombardiert würden jetzt sind allerdings
ja viele auf Israels Anweisung gerade
erst in diesen Süden geflüchtet da
stellt sich natürlich die Frage wo
sollen denn die Menschen jetzt noch
hin also seit 6 Wochen kommunizieren wir
eigentlich oder mittlerweile ja seit 5
Wochen mittlerweile dass die Menschen in
den Südteil gehen und zwear in eine ganz
bestimmte Region im Süden und die Region
heißt Almasi das habe ich mindestens in
2000 Interviews jetzt schon betont
Almasi liegt westlich von chunes am
Mittelmeer und da ist ein großes Lager
wo es Medizin Nahrung Wasser gibt wo die
UN Vorort ist wo die lastbahn
hinkommen in diesem Lager sollen 2,3
Millionen Menschen aus Gaza Zuflucht
suchen 2,3 Millionen Menschen minus den
Terroristen die sich unter den
Zivilisten in Krankenhäusern in Schulen
in Wohngebieten verschanzt halten und
nach wie vor Raketen auf Israel
abschießen wir reden hier über 10.000
Raketen die in den letzten 6 Wochen aus
diesen gaserstreifen auf auf Israel
abgefallen muss man sich fragen von wo
wurden diese Raketen abgeschossen es
gibt in in im Gasastreifen nicht eine
einzige Militärkaserne wie es in Berlin
z.B die Julius leberkerne gibt das gibt
es nicht diese Raketen werden aus
zivilen Infrastrukturen nach wie vor
abgeschossen und wir müssen uns dagegen
verteidigen es wird natürlich für 2,3
Millionen Menschen auf einem ganz winzig
kleinen Fleck der ihnen dann noch bleibt
sehr sehr schwierig werden jetzt sagt
die UNO fast die Hälfte aller Wohnungen
in Gaza sein mittlerweile entweder
zerstört oder beschädigt kann es das
Ziel sein dass Gaza was ja die größte
Stadt der Palästinenser weltweit ist
unbewohnbar
wird na ja zum einen wünschte ich mir
dass die UN auch ein Stück weit mal nach
Israel guckt und dort feststellt dass 8
Millionen Israelis von 10 Millionen
unter ständigem Raketenbeschuss Leben
das heißt 8 Millionen Menschen in
ständiger Angst davon 500.000 die nicht
in ihren eigenen Wohnungen wohnen das
heißt auch in Israel findet eine
humanitäre Katastrophe Stadt über die
nicht geredet wird wenn wir aber in den
Gasastreifen gucken da ist die Hamas
einzig und alle allein schuldig für
diese Situation weil bis zum 7 Oktober
gab es hier Waffenstillstand wer den
Waffenstillstand gebrochen hat ist die
Hamas Terrororganisation die nach Israel
eingebrungen ist über000 den Punkt haben
sie ja gerade bereits gemacht die Frage
ist allerdings jetzt kann es das Ziel
sein dass man den Gasastreifen komplett
unbewohnbar
macht das ist absolut nicht das Ziel im
Gegenteil wir haben auch gar kein
Interesse an Krieg wir hatten auch kein
Interesse an Krieg unser Interesse liegt
in zwei zwei Punkten der eine Punkt ist
dass die Hamas für dieses Massaker
natürlich den Preis bezahlt und dort
nach diesem Krieg nicht mehr regiert das
heißt ihre terrorinfrastruktur komplett
zerstören das zweite Ziel ist natürlich
dass 200 über 230 Geisen die nach vor
sich in den terrortuneln der famamas
befinden dass sie entweder freigelassen
werden oder von uns befreit werden wenn
die famasterrorganisation heute alle 230
plus Geiseln befreit bzw freilässt dann
werden wir heute schon in einer anderen
Situation jetzt muss man sich fragen was
sind die Prioritäten der
Hamas jetzt sagt der Premierminister von
Israel Benjamin Netanyahu wir versuchen
diesen Krieg mit minimalen zivilen
Opfern zu führen leider sind wir da
nicht erfolgreich nehmen sie als Armee
diese Kritik ihres Premierministers
an das ist keine Kritik sondern das ist
einfach eine ganz klare Blick in den
Spiegel sage ich jetzt mal dass man in
einer Situation wo man gegen Terroristen
kämpft die sich verschanzen hinter
Frauen hinter Kindern in Krankenhäusern
in Moscheen in Schulen dass da natürlich
auch zivile Opfer leider der Fall sind
die natürlich der Hamas zu verschulden
sind weil würden sie Raketen aus
Militärkasernen schießen dann wä die
Hamas an einem Tag schon zerstört an
einem
Tag sie wissen sie kämpfen ja nicht zum
ersten Mal als israelische Armee gegen
die Hamas Terroristen es ist mehrfach
schon in der Vergangenheit passiert
Israel weiß auch irgendwann wird der
internationale Druck sehr groß zumal
wenn es viele viele tote Zivilisten gibt
ähm sie haben das in der Vergangenheit
immer damit begründet insbesondere auch
den Sturm auf das schiferkrankenhaus
dass dort unter diesem Krankenhaus das
zentrale Hauptquartier in mehreren
Ebenen der Hamas zu finden sei wir
kennen die Computeranimation der
israelischen Armee dazu Kommandobunker
mehrere Etagen jetzt hat Israels Armee
ja seit mehreren Tagen dieses
schieferkrankenhaus unter seiner
Kontrolle unter ihrer Kontrolle warum
haben Sie dieses Hamas Hauptquartier
bislang nicht
gefunden na ja zum einen ich glaube man
versteht nicht ganz was eine
terrorkommandozentrale bedeutet noch
einmal wir reden hier im Sachen chramas
nicht über eine Julius leberkaserne das
ist nicht eine Kaserne von 5 x 5 km
Umfang sondern das sind kleine
terrorzentralen die embeddet sind
innerhalb der zivilen Bevölkerung
insbesondere in Krankenhäusern wo man in
diesem Krankenhauskomplex von 20 30
Gebäuden zwei drei Gebäude als
terrorzentralen hat davon einige
Abteilung vierter Stockwerk siebter
Stockwerk und dann natürlich
unterirdisch und das nicht in einem
Krankenhaus sondern in vielen
Krankenhäusern und das ist genau die
Vorgehensweise deras ja major scholiker
kann es sein dass sie das dieses
Hauptquartier dass Sie vorhermer
beschrieben haben als eine große
Einrichtung operatives Zentrum aller
Hamas Operationen kann es sein dass es
das dort gar nicht
gibt also erst einmal das ist lustig
dass sie das so sagen Herr sias und wir
kennen uns se so vielen Jahren sie
kennen die Situation hier in Israel und
das eine hauptk wenn es da nur in diesem
Krankenhaus gebe dann woher werden denn
diese 10.000 Raketen
geschossen na vielleicht aus dieser
Kommandozentrale oder ich gebe nur das
wieder was Israels Armee vor dem Sturm
auf das Krankenhaus gesagt hatte
dazu wir haben erstmal gar keinen Sturm
auf ein Krankenhaus gemacht sondern wir
sind sehr präzise und langsam
vorgegangen wir sind nicht aus der Luft
vorgegangen um zivile Opfer zu vermeiden
sondern nur zu Fuß und das seit wenigen
Tagen natürlich sehr präzise in
bestimmten Ecken dieses Krankenhauses in
Kooperation sogar mit dem medizinischen
Team und den Zivilisten und den
Patienten um sie nicht zu verwunden
hätten wir es anders machen wollen
hätten wir einfach aus der Luft
angegriffen und dann wäre die Sache sehr
schnell geregelt gewesen haben wir aber
nicht gemacht wer diese Situation hier
verfolgt der weiß dass aus dem gesamten
Gazastreifen nicht nur Raketen auf
Israel abgefeuert werden sondern auch
aus dem gesamten Gazastreifen am 7
Oktober Terrorzellen der Hamas mit
tausenden Terroristen und
palästinensischen Mob nach Israel
eingedrungen sind ermordet haben
vergewaltigt haben und nach wie vor 230
Geiseln in ihren Händen halten sagt der
Sprecher der israelischen Armee major
Ari schalika herzlichen Dank für das
Gespräch nach Tel Aviv
schalom wir haben jetzt hier weitere
wichtige Nachrichten von heute
zusammengefasst von dir Gundula der
Haushaltsausschuss des Bundestages hat
in einer langen Nachtsitzung über die
Folgen des
bundesverfassungsgerichtsurteils beraten
und entschieden der ETA 24 wird erst am
kommenden Donnerstag beschlossen nach
weiteren Änderungen vereinbart hat der
Ausschuss unter anderem dass die
geplanten Kürzungen im sozialen Sektor
zurückgenommen werden sollen die
bundesfreiwillendienste werden sogar
zusätzlich gefördert auch der Erhöhung
des Bürgergeldes stimmte der Ausschuss
zu Mehrkosten
3,4 Milliarden
Euro im Bundestag beschlossen wurden die
gesetzlichen Regelungen zur me plananung
in Städten und Gemeinden eine der
Voraussetzungen für den heizungsumbau in
Deutschland denn spätestens ab Mitte
2028 sollen alle neuen Heizungen zu
mindestens
65% mit erneuerbaren Energien laufen
nach dem Gesetz müssen Großstädte bis
Mitte 26 ihre Konzepte zur
Wärmeversorgung aufstellen Städte mit
weniger als 100.000 Einwohnern haben
zwei Jahre länger Zeit kurz nach dem
ersten Warnstreik im Tarifstreit mit der
Deutschen Bahn hat die Gewerkschaft GDL
ihre Mitglieder zur Urabstimmung
aufgerufen sie sollen über unbefristete
Streiks bei der Bahn und anderen
Verkehrsunternehmen entscheiden erklärte
gdlchef weselski ein Zeitrahmen wurde
bislang nicht benannt auf dem
Bundesparteitag der Linken werden
Möglichkeiten eines Neuanfangs
diskutiert das Kapitel um die Abspaltung
der Gruppe um Sarah Wagenknecht erklärte
parteichf Schirdewan für beendet auch
coparteichefin Wissler will von Augsburg
aus ein Zeichen der Erneuerung senden
nach dieser zesur so Schirdewan gebe es
auch eine große Chance zur Stärkung der
Linken gebraucht werde eine
sozialistische
gerechtigkeitspartei die sich für eine
Umverteilung von oben nach unten
Einsätze
für Bundeskanzler Scholz zeigt sich die
Zukunft Deutschlands in der Entwicklung
des Ostens auf der Konferenz
Ostdeutschland 2030 Heimat und Zukunft
erklärte Scholz in Leipzig er verkenne
die Probleme im Osten nicht das
Erstarken der rechten Kräfte besorge ihn
gemeinsam mit den Ministerpräsidenten
der ostdeutschen Bundesländer
Ungleichgewichte bei Vermögen Eigentum
und auch bei spositionen müssten weiter
abgebaut
werden die einflussreichste und größte
Ausstellung für Gegenwartskunst auf der
Welt war mal in Kassel sie war denn seit
dem Antisemitismus eklar bei der letzten
Ausgabe der Dokumenta die von einem
indonesischen Künstlerkollektiv
kuratiert worden war ist der Ruf ohnehin
angeknackst und jetzt stellen die ersten
die ganz große Frage nämlich ob die
Dokumenta komplett am Ende ist klar ist
sie hat für die kommende Ausgabe aktuell
weder ein Konzept noch eine
Organisationsstruktur nicht mal die
Kommission die darüber entscheiden
sollte wer künftig über die Dokumenta
entscheidet gibt es noch auch die
letzten Mitglieder sind jetzt
zurückgetreten die Situation für Kassel
ist verheerend spiegelt aber ein
größeres Bild der Nahostkonflikt spaltet
auch die internationale Kunstwelt Isabel
D
Weger die skandalbilder der letzten
Dokumenta Antisemitismus im Namen der
Kunstfreiheit erst verhüllt dann
abgehängt nie wieder hieß es Judenhass
auf der weltgrößten Kunstschau die
dokumenter muss sich ganz klar von
Antisemitismus nach den Ereignissen
gerade des Sommers
2022 umfassend distanzieren doch der
Reformversuch ist erstmal krachend
gescheitert alle Mitglieder der
Kommission für die Wahl einer neuen
künstlerischen Leitung der Dokumenta
sind
zurückgetreten der indische Autor Ranjit
hoscoti vergangene Woche noch Mitglied
der dokumenterkommission hatte 2019 eine
Erklärung der anti-israelischen BDS
beewegung unterschrieben Zitat der
Zionismus ist eine rassistische
Ideologie die einen
siedlerkolonialistischen
apaththeitsstaat verlangt in dem
Nichtjuden nicht die gleichen Rechte
haben und der in der Praxis aus der
ethnischen Reinigung von Palästinensern
in den letzten 7 Jahren steht Entsetzen
bei der Geschäftsleitung man habe die
Mitglieder der Kommission sorgfältig
ausgewählt das ist
dann trotzdem zu diesem Fall der
Unterzeichnung eines Statements mit
antisemitischen Inhalten ganz klar
antisemitischen Inhalten durch ranget
hoscoti im Jahr 2019 gekommen ist und
dass dieser
Fall nicht bekannt war ist ein Fehler in
diesem Prozess hos Coy tritt aus der
Kommission aus er sei schockiert in der
Öffentlichkeit als Antisemit bezeichnet
zu werden verurteile die Massaker der
Hamas aufs
schärfste in dem BDS Statement steht
kein Satz der das jüdische Volk
attackiert es ist eine Kritik an
bestimmten Politikern an ihrer Ideologie
die sie trägt und das was in ihrem Namen
geschieht wovon sich hosti distanziert
der es ruft auch zum boyott israelischer
Künstler auf wenn man sagt einerseits
ich bin gegen kultureller boyott und
andererseits ein Brief unterschreibt der
offiziell von der BDS bewergung
herausgegeben wurde meine hier eine
gewisse Widerspruch zu sehen und diese
diese mulmigiges Gefühl der damit einher
geht also ist Herr hoskotte wirklich in
der Lage israelische Künstler
gleichberechtig zu bewerten diese
Verdacht kann zu diesem Zeitpunkt nicht
ausgeräumt werden
für ihre Kritiker laufe die dokumenter
nun Gefahr die globale Perspektive zu
verlieren wollen Sie jetzt die
politischen Einstellungen aller dort
prüfen ihre Biografien dann werden Sie
bald ein komplettes Überwachungssystem
haben so spaltet der Krieg in Gaza die
Kunstwelt und jede Seite vermisst
Verständnis für das Leid der anderen
diese innere Empörung die die wir in
diese Jahren in der Vergangenheit immer
gesehen haben wenn esemistische
Anschläge unser Leben getroffen haben
das war nicht zu sehen am 17 oktober bis
2027 ist noch Zeit den Reformprozess der
Dokumenta zu
retten der Haushaltsausschuss des
Bundestages hat in seiner
Bereinigungssitzung auch beschlossen den
Kapitalstock für die aktienrente zu
erhöhen das aus Krediten finanzierte
Kapital soll um 12 auf 22 Milliarden
Euro aufgestockt werden und langfristig
die Rentenversicherung entlasten
Rentenniveau und Beiträge
stabilisieren und zur Ankurbelung der
lahmenden deutschen Wirtschaft hat der
Bundestag das sogenannte
wachstumschancengesetz beschlossen das
soll Unternehmen steuerlich deutlich
entlasten Frank betmann womit kann die
Wirtschaft konkret rechnen ein Kernpunkt
des Maßnahmenpakets ist eine Prämie für
Investitionen in den Klimaschutz also
wenn sich Unternehmen entscheiden
Energie einzusparen beispielsweise durch
hocheffiziente wärmepumpten dann soll
das direkt bezuschusst werden zudem wird
es steuerliche Anreize geben vor allem
für den kriselnden Wohnungsbau und für
die Forschung hier will man also Impulse
setzen und
Genehmigungsverfahren sollen
beschleunigt werden nach Angaben der
Bundesregierung kostet das
wachstumschancengesetz in den nächsten 5
Jahren rund 32 Milliarden Euro und wie
reagiert die deutsche Wirtschaft sieht
sie Risiken oder eher Chancen da stecken
Chancen drin zweifels ohne doch Experten
monieren viel zu geringe tatsächliche
Steuerentlastungen für Unternehmen
minimale Wachstumsimpulse zu der
Erkenntnis kommt auch das
arbeitgebernahe Institut der deutschen
Wirtschaft in einer Studie ihre Autoren
schreiben darin unter anderem auch wenn
die Schritte in die richtige Richtung
gehen ist der Effekt auf die
Investitionstätigkeit und das deutsche
brutto Inlandsprodukt voraussichtlich
gering deutliche Kritik ern auch die
Länder und Kommunen die steuerlichen
Entlastung müssten sie zu zwei Dritteln
tragen sehr wahrscheinlich also dass das
Gesetz den Bundesrat erstmal nicht
passiert und im Vermittlungsausschuss
landet Frank betmann vielen Dank für die
Einschätzung der US Pharmakonzern Eli
lilli hat den Bau eines neuen Werkes im
rheinlandfelsischen allzei bestätigt
Wirtschaftsminister habbeck erklärte die
Ansiedlung zeige das Vertrauen der
Unternehmen in die Attraktivität des
Industriestandortes Deutschland rund 2,3
Milliarden Euro will Lilli in die neue
Hightech faabrik investieren ohne
staatliche Subventionen ab
2027 sollen dort vor allem
Diabetesmittel hergestellt
werden Vorlesen verbindet unter diesem
Motto hat in zahlreichen Schulen Kitas
Bibliotheken und Museen der 20
bundesweite Vorlesetag stattgefunden
mehr als eine Million Menschen
beteiligten sich an der Aktion Zuhörer
und Vorleser darunter auch Polizistinnen
die Grundschulkindern vorlasen mit ganz
eigenem Engagement einen
Kinderkrimi Ziel des jährlichen
Vorlesetages initiiert von der Stiftung
Lesen der Zeit und der Deutsche
bahnstiftung ist Lust aufs Lesen zu
machen toll am besten wä es wenn jeden
Tag Vorlesetag ist damit sagen wir danke
für heute und würden uns freuen wenn Sie
auch morgen wieder dabei sind um 015 uh
meldet sich nasan göckte mir mit unserem
heute journal Update und von uns beiden
hier im Namen des gesamten Teams einen
angenehmen Abend tchü
[Musik]
tschüss ja guten Abend zwischen die
Tiefs die uns im Moment diesen
verregneten Herbst bringen schiebt sich
morgen mal ein zwischen hoch und was
bedeutet das nun dieses Hoch sorgt in
Kombination mit diesem abziehenden tief
dafür dass sich etwas mehr Kälte in
unser Wetter mischt aber morgen
Nachmittag ist das ganze schon wieder
vorbei da erreicht uns eine Warmfront
mit Regen und wieder sehr milder Luft
aber noch nicht heute Nacht da sinken
die Werte auf 4 bis 0° zwischen der
Nordsee und dem Bayerischen Wald und an
den Alp ist eben Frost möglich bis -3°
und dann kann es örtlich auch glatt
werden denn es bildet sich teils dicht
der Nebel und im Süden und anfangs auch
im Südwesten gibt's Regen oberhalb von
700 m noch Schnee die vereinzelten
Schauer an der Ostsee und im sächsischen
Bergland lassen morgen Vormittag dann
rasch nach auch in den östlichen Alpen
wird's schnell trocken und trocken bei
wechselnder Bewölkung startet der Tag
morgen nachmittags kommt dann von Westen
der teils kräftige Regen bei einem
starkbögen auf Süd drehenden Wind unter
diesen Regenwolken liegen die
Temperaturen morgen schon bei 7 bis 10°
im Bergland und im Osten aber noch bei 4
bis 7° am Sonntag wird's dann deutlich
milder bei einem starken Südwestwind
gibt's teils 15° am oberrein dazu
Schauerwetter mit vereinzelten Gewittern
im Osten noch der kräftigere Regen bei
nur 8° und am Montag und am Dienstag
gibt's viel Regen etwas trüb ist es und
am Montag am Mittwoch da wird's dann
richtig kühl bei nur noch 0 bis 7°
tschüss